hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast capturing cocaine
memories in the Perry neuronal net I'm
Suzy Valdez of lab roots and I will be
your moderator for today's events lab
roots is the leading scientific social
networking site and we are extremely
proud to bring you this interactive web
seminar for more information visit us at
lab roots com here's how this
presentation will work today we want to
hear from you so questions comments and
even answers can be submitted via the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
your screen we'll try to get to everyone
but if not we'll make sure to follow up
with you by email you can also enlarge
the slide window by clicking on the
screen icon in a lower right hand corner
of the slide window if you cannot hear
or see this presentation properly let us
know by clicking on the support button
at the top right or the Q&A button at
the lower left this is an educational
webinar and this offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the C e button
located on the bottom left-hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credits I would now
like to introduce a wonderful speaker
for today dr. Barbara sword professor
sword received her PhD in biochemistry
from the University of Maryland she is
currently a professor in the department
of integrative physiology and
neuroscience at Washington State
University she is the former director of
the alcohol and drug abuse research
program and currently co-director of the
translation addiction research program
the main projects and dr. swords
laboratory focuses on how to prevent
relapse in cocaine in rats she uses
conditioned place preference and drugged
self administration procedures to
diminish cocaine associated memories
that are thought to cause relapse
behavior the majority of our studies
examined the rule of the structure
called Perry neuronal Nets that
contribute to brain plasticity other
studies focus on using these same models
of drug addiction to
determine how Perry neuronal nets are
influenced by day/night cycle and by
sleep it's now time to present our
speaker dr. Barbara sort thank you Susie
and thank you for the opportunity to
share my work that we've been doing over
the last few years on the role of Perry
neuronal nets in capturing cocaine
memories these are nets are shown here
in green these are these beautiful
little structures that wrap around just
certain neurons within the brain and the
spinal cord today what I want to talk
with you about are three main topics and
that is the peri neural nets or PMS as
I'll call them what peri neural nets are
and why we think they are present in the
brain and then go on and talk about the
research we've been doing and look at
the contribution of PNM's to cocaine
associated memory and then help enns
themselves change after exposure to
cocaine so Camillo Golgi first described
the intracellular reticulum which we're
now all very familiar with it's called
the Golgi apparatus but he equally
emphasized this peripheral reticulum
which we now call peri neural nets and
he described this as a kind of corset of
neuro keratin which impeded the spread
of current from cell to cell if you look
at this depiction of goal G's paranormal
Nets you can see especially in the
bottom section here this kind of lattice
like structure with holes in it and a
more modern picture is shown here this
green part here is the paranormal net
and that is wrapping around both the
soma of the of the neuron and then these
proximal dendrites shown here if you
look up the close-up in the lower left
you see that the where the holes are
located is where the synaptic Bouton's
come in and synapse onto the underlying
neuron now this is a closer version of
what we see in a peri neuronal met and
from much work that's been done today we
know that there are four critical
components for different types of
molecules that are very important
on the left hand side here you can see
the list of those molecules and then on
the right side we I can show you what
those four molecules are first is hilar
on em and that is this long backbone you
see in purple a backbone of hyaluronic
just this sugar groups and those are
extruded by hyaluronic acid synthase
shown by the little square that's that's
um hyaluronic acid synthase enzyme
embedded within the membrane of the
neurons that extrude higher on second is
the elect ecclectic cams and these are
also referred to as congruent sulfate
proteoglycans there's a core protein
shown in green here the core protein and
then a glycosylated it's chemically
heavily glycosylated and those glyco
solutes have sulfur sulfate groups on
them so this is congruent sulfate
proteoglycans the third group of
proteins that's important they're called
linked proteins those are shown in pink
here these pink dots and those link the
electic hands to the hyaluronic backbone
and then forth and finally is to Mason
art to nice and our other proteins that
bind to the opposite end of the elect
cans and together form this whole
lattice like structure that wraps around
these neurons the PN ends first appeared
during development and what I've shown
you here is a rat prefrontal cortex on
the left and a human prefrontal cortex
on the right and just before I forget to
mention these be often labeled these
nets with shown in green here for the
rat profile cortex with wisteria
floribunda glutenin which is a plant
lectin WFA that binds to these nets and
but you can see is it postnatal day 21
and the rat is there really no nets
formed yet and so it's not until late
adolescents probably forty to at least
fifty days in the prefrontal cortex that
these nets are fully formed so on the
right hand side is the adult mats and
you can see these are really well formed
that's very part eight kind of staining
and
and intense staining around both the
cell body and the proximal dendrites in
the human prefrontal cortex we see the
same picture around 20 years of late
adolescence is when those nets are fully
formed their formation is really
interesting in that it marks the end of
the critical period of brain development
for example in the visual cortex the
ocular dominance these are very
important and market period of when
ocular dominance plasticity closes that
is that window of opportunity when
there's still plasticity and so they
that Co terminates with the closure of
ocular dominance plasticity during
development the formation of Nets is
dependent on neural activity in the
underlying neurons and that's been shown
with the activity dependent on potassium
calcium and the glutamate receptors NMDA
and also calcium permeable alpha
receptors so those all promote the
formation of these peri new elements
during development the function of Perry
neural Nets is many fold and one they
stabilize synaptic context it kind of
contact so if you look at a on the right
hand side they form a physical barrier
to new synaptic inputs coming in so the
net is shown around a neuron and the new
synaptic inputs have a more difficult
time forming new synapses and
interestingly shown on B is these Nets
also capture inhibitory molecules shown
in these little X's that are placed on
the net an example of this that's been
studied probably the most today is
semaphore in 3a a chemo repulsive agent
that keeps new new synapse formation or
new incoming synapses and then another
function is shown and see here is
they've been demonstrated to restrict
lateral mobility of receptors in
particular anti-glue to make receptors
so the receptors cannot show lateral
mobility and this may decrease some
excitatory activity in the underline
and third they protect from oxidative
stress I'll come back to this topic a
little bit later but they do protect the
underlying neurons from that oxidative
burden oxidative stress and then they
are also believed to regulate the ionic
micro environment and the way they do
this if you look up in the right-hand
corner where the nets are there are a
lot of negative charges that are
associated with those sulfate groups on
the congruent sulfate proteoglycans that
I mentioned that make up the net and so
these negative groups are thought to
serve as buffering capacity for
positively charged molecules like
calcium perhaps potassium and also
glutamate so what's exciting about
pairing our Nets
well one of the things that's been found
through the years is that if you remove
these Nets you can reinstate brain
plasticity and more importantly you can
reinstate juvenile like states of brain
plasticity so this has been shown in the
visual system I already have mentioned
this with that ocular dominance
plasticity
if those Nets are removed in adulthood
you can reinstate that window that
critical critical period they're also
important in recovery from spinal cord
injury removal of Nets can promote the
recovery from spinal cord injury PNM's
are reduced in individuals with
schizophrenia and in animal models of
schizophrenia and this may be related to
the fact that peri neural Nets largely
wrap around parvalbumin fast-spiking
neurons that control output in the
prefrontal cortex in particular and so
these may be important for the loss of
cognitive ability in individuals with
schizophrenia and then finally they've
been shown in different studies to be
important for learning and memory and
I'd like to point out that not only
could they prevent certain types of or
promote certain types of learning such
as extinction learning they may also
prevent certain types of learning
induced by other stimuli and that's
where our studies came into the picture
phone with cocaine because cocaine is a
strong stimulus that induces its own
learning and memory so we asked
but about drug memories and in
particular memories that we believe
drives relapse behavior so what is the
contribution of Perry neural nets to
coaching associated memories so we have
to think about what these drug memories
are so first we think about accumulating
these drug memories well memory for how
the drug would make one feel and that
would be including the euphoric effects
shown here on the top and then also a
most bottom this is supposed to depict
the withdrawal effects of negative
effects and maybe I'm hedonic effects of
drugs and so these internal cues that
are induced by drugs first when they
come on and then when the drugs come off
and what's wrong effects into and so
these are partly creating these memories
and then there's a memory for the drug
environment so this would be the
environment where one might take drugs
or would get their drugs and their
memories for these drug use so the very
discrete cues that become associated
with taking these drugs so I kind of
written this is just a composite drug
memory in the center here and all of
these we believe contribute in a large
part to the motivation to continue to
use the drugs and relapse in taking
these drugs so our focus then is on how
to diminish those cocaine associated
memories to think about how to diminish
memories we have to take a look at how
memories are consolidated and
reconsolidated and in other words how
they required when they're initially
consolidated somewhere in the brain
likely many locations in the brain and
then also how these memories are
maintained by the process of
reconsolidation
so to look at these processes or just
take an example of a drug experience
that is consolidated or stabilized
somewhere in the brain or in multiple
parts of the brain and I just call this
a stored drug memory now we know that
stored drug memories aren't forever they
can be retrieved and they can be altered
in some way so when these memories are
retrieved or recalled or as a
later say reactivated every time these
memories are retrieved they are
susceptible to strengthening or perhaps
weakening or updating and this is
because these memories for a certain
period of time probably several minutes
to hours become unstable and therefore
labile so they could either be
strengthened they could be weakened or
they could be updated and that's by the
process of reconsolidation where that
memory could be destabilized back into
the storage memory State
this reconsolidation process requires
molecular events and in fact probably
several molecular events many of these
have been have been explored in the in
the last 15 years or so and the fact
that there are several molecular beds
means that you would you could
potentially block some of these events
and reduce reconsolidation of block
reconsolidation of memory and therefore
reduce that stored drug memory in some
fashion and we don't know if a blocking
reconsolidation reduces the stored
memory or impairs the ability to
retrieve that memory and that that has
not been determined yet regardless the
idea is that we could take a store drug
memory and potentially block it in some
way or diminish it in some way so that
we could decrease relapse and that would
be our ultimate goal so we can think of
this as this is one example I like to
give of updating memory so we're always
updating our memories and in some way
either enhancing or diminishing or
updating and changing them out in some
way so if you think of when you were
small you think of the word president
and President conjured up this image of
a bleep George Washington and later on
maybe talked about Abe Lincoln and
through the years you've updated this
memory to think about what President
what president means to you and so
depending on your age and this is
probably showing my age here because I
could think of this president first in
my in my memories and through the years
this has been updated for better or for
worse
through the years and here's where we
are now of course so coming back to the
circuitry involved in drug reward and
thinking about where these peri neural
Nets may be important I've been focusing
my work in the last several years on the
medial prefrontal cortex here so this is
a rat brain a sagittal section of the
rat brain showing you lots of
connections that are important in this
circuitry that's important for rewards
so we're focus is on the medial
prefrontal cortex and so we'll dig in a
little bit deeper here is generally now
a slice a coronal slice of the medial
prefrontal cortex and a rat in this area
here that we're interested in targeting
for our studies the reason for this is
that there are pyramidal neurons in
these in the pre limbic region of the
prefrontal cortex that have important
outputs to the nucleus accumbens or
relapse behavior so we think of relapse
behavior in individuals in in drug
addicts we measured this in animals but
we call it reinstatement so I will be
talking much of this the rest of this is
talking about reinstatement rather than
relapse so we know these outputs are
very important from some previous work
that's been done showing over here on
the right side but one of the things
you're very interested in is what's
controlling those pyramidal neurons
those are very important again for
relapse but there's an upstream control
of those neurons and those are by these
GABAergic intern neurons located in the
prefrontal cortex those contain
parvalbumin they're fast-spiking neurons
and they can powerfully inhibit the
output of pyramidal neurons now the
reason that we're very interested in
these nets and I mean in these neurons
in particular is that 75 to 80 percent
of these GABAergic part of human neurons
have carry normal Nets surrounding them
and so we're interested what the role of
these Nets is in this mean statement
behavior and so what I'm showing you
here and the lower-left yes the Nets you
so peri normal Nets labeled in green
and then in the middle panel is part
albumin in red and then the overlay so
you can see that there are several part
of albumin neurons that are surrounded
by next so we're looking at what is the
contribution by paranormal nets in the
prefrontal cortex to the cocaine
associated memory for that we used a
couple of different animal models of
addiction one of these is called the
conditioned place preference model and
most of you should be familiar with
conditioned police preference if you
like to do it coffee and your workplace
you may go to the place where they make
coffee or where you make coffee every
morning you've been conditioned to
prefer that place because it contains
something you like and so what we do in
the rat model is we take in a rat and we
put that you know three chambered box a
white side a gray side a black side
typically well put the rat in the box
and ask it where it would like to spend
its time so the animal is kind of
getting an initial preference and I'll
wander around the box it's deciding
where it likes to be so a couple of days
later we take that same animal and we
give it an injection of cocaine try to
recreate the environment of cocaine and
then we confine it by closing the door
and letting the animal experience this
cocaine feeling the internal sensations
of cocaine for about 20 or 30 minutes
the next day we take the animal and we
put it on the opposite side and give it
a boring staylene injection and confine
it to the other side so this has no just
like a stimulant effects the way cocaine
does and so we can retrain the animals
day after day alternating between the
cocaine side and the Saline side and
then on the final test day we take the
animal and put it in the center and ask
where it would like to spend its time
and the animal most animals inevitably
will go sigh spend their time on the
cocaine paired side so what we're
looking at is how much time they spend
here initially and how much time they
spend here after they've been trained so
we come back to the question of
ParaNorman net
surrounded cells activated by a cocaine
associated memories and that was our
first question and this was done by
Megan Slager who is now a postdoc at the
Medical College of Wisconsin and Megan
was very into her PhD project so much so
that at one of the Halloween parties she
showed up dressed up as a paranormal met
herself so here's what we did
what Megan did was she trained the
animals as I just mentioned cocaine on
one side singing on the other side and
then after a period of time what she did
after they were trained which she
confined the animal to either the
cocaine paired side for the Sailing
paired side and so this would reactivate
the memory on the cocaine side and that
was the idea and then a few hours later
she measured what happened in the
pairing neural nets and she looked at
the intensity of these nets and she also
then looked at the number of neurons
that are surrounded by nets expressing C
pass which is a marker for activation of
neurons and this is all in the pre
limbic cortex what she found was she
measured this the Seabus cells that was
surrounded by pairing around 1s and you
can see in the white bar these animals
were confined to the Saline side but the
blue bar shows the animals confined to
the cocaine side and you see a greater
activation of cephas neurons in the
prefrontal cortex that are surrounded by
paranormal Mets so it looks like a
cocaine memory does activate these
neurons that are surrounded by nests so
next she asked the question could she
disrupt consolidation of the drug memory
and the cocaine memory in particular do
we need Perry neuronal Nets there and
secondly do we need Perry neuronal Nets
with the pre consolidation process so
what she did was she used the most
common way to destroy Nets and that is
to give this enzyme chondroitin ace ABC
or CH ABC and what I'm showing you here
on the lower right you
that these nets can be disrupted with
Chondroitin ace ABC this is an enzyme
and this happens within probably a
couple of hours we usually test animals
days later because this lasts for a
fairly a long time and I'll get back to
that issue about how long how long this
lasts so she disrupted these pianet
parry neural nets this is before the
enzyme on the left side here we use our
pac-man to depict enzymes this eh ABC
enzyme and then afterwards just three
days later this is what it looks like so
you might see an occasion when that I
don't know if you could pick one out
there in the right hand side see very
lightly stained Nets or none at all
three days later
we've also not showing you the data but
on CH ABC does not call us underlying
cells to die this has been shown by us
as well as other labs so what she did
was she said well let's get this on
vehicle just vehicle or CH ABC to the
animals and the prelim Baker prefrontal
cortex and then train them as I
mentioned before and then test them and
so what I will show you is the results
of that test day on the left side is
shown the behavior and what you're
looking at on this y-axis is the time
spent in the cocaine paired side so if
you look at the initial preference day
the white bars show you that in vehicle
treated animals they showed more time
they spend on the cocaine paired side
after training but you see a reduction
of this the blue bars after CH ABC
showing that perineural on that
destruction does not allow the animals
to acquire this memory as well on the
right hand side has shown the double
label cells the C foss neurons
surrounded by W by pairing around
linette's that's labeled by WFA so these
double label cells are also reduced so
it mirrors what we see with behavior and
then also Megan also did some studies to
show that a nearby brain region if you
look at the upper left panel here
she went just ventral to the pre limbic
cortex down into the intra limbic cortex
to see if a nearby site would affect the
memory the same way and she found it did
not so you can see in the bar graph here
that the CH ABC treated animals how do
not have the memory affected so they
test just fine then she wanted to test
for memory reconsolidation so i wanted
to show you how we test for memory
reconsolidation and that is to go ahead
is to go ahead and train the animals for
this condition placed preference there
CPP and then after a period of
extinction and what this is is we
basically place the rat in the box day
after day until they no longer show a
preference in the cocaine paired side so
we're kind of over writing this memory
and extinguishing that response and and
then we give the vehicle or the CH ABC
into the prefrontal cortex and now we
have to reactivate the memory just like
I showed you earlier we'd have to
reactivate that memory to make it become
labile for a period of time the way that
she did this was to give a cocaine
injection and essentially it's a
reminder of what the cocaine felt like
and the animal will spend more time on
that white side of the box again and
then at a later date and this was
several days later in this case she
reinstates the memory and the way we do
that is again to give a cocaine
injection it's a it's another reminder
so our question here is do the rats
maintain that cocaine memory once it's
been reactivated in the absence of next
and so on the top is showing you pretty
much the same thing I just described if
you look from left right there's a the
CPP training that she did the testing
and the extinction that I mentioned then
the injection the ABC into the
prefrontal cortex and then she either
reactivated the memory as I said before
with cocaine where she had another group
that received no reactivation as a
control group and then after a period of
time she did some more extinction or
just let them sit in the home cage and
tested on the last day the day shown
here the statement day whether the
memory was maintained
so first I'll show you the results of
animals that had their memories
reactivated Fannett shown here on the
left side is the behavior we see very
much the same thing as as we saw before
for consolidation and that's that CA CH
ABC tweeted animals that is animals with
no nets show a diminished behavior
response compared with their controls so
it looks like they are not
reconsolidated memory or maintaining
their memory as well as controls we see
that mirrored in the seat bas activation
and the prefrontal cortex so these are
C+ neurons surrounded by paranormal Mets
you know and there's a decrease in the
activation of those of course we have to
know that the treatment with ch ABC by
itself does not somehow just impaired
memory whether it's reactivate or do not
so we have a control group of no
reactivation so that is these animals
received vehicle or CH ABC in the home
cage and that's it and then they were
tested later of being statement and that
group is shown here so when we don't
reactivate the memory we see no changes
in the responses or behavior so they
conditioned place preference just fine
and we see no differences in the C
thoughts activation so it appears then
that giving Manette's
even after training can prevent
maintenance of those memories and one
thing that we wanted to check was I or
was that I would like to show you - and
you checked was how how well with these
nuts reformed two weeks later because
this is the period of time between when
the CH ABC was given and when the
animals were reinstated and that's shown
here so on the left side has shown
vehicle treated rats both with a lower
magnification and higher magnification
shown in the left side oh and then I
showed you before what happens after ch
ABC this was three days later could see
very few maybe one net very lightly
stained and then you can see about two
weeks later these nets are starting to
beat
but you could see that the Nats they
look at the higher magnification on the
right-hand side those nets have not been
fully reformed and they're very thin and
not very intense and really generally
not wrapped around the dendrites and
then this is a quantification of that so
nine days later and about two weeks
later we still see that the intensity of
the Nets has not been restored to normal
and we believe that the intensity of the
net matters and that will be alluding to
that we're talking about that in a few
minutes so then secondly we did a few
studies we were just beginning some of
these studies using the gold standard
for addiction models and that is a self
administration model where the animal
learns to press a lever to receive
cocaine in our case so this animal has a
tether you can see this tether on the
animal this is an IV line that's hooked
up so that when the animal presses the
lever it gets a small amount of cocaine
the other thing is when the animal
presses the lever is hard to see in this
picture but it's just below his nose he
looks like he's pressing it with his
nose on his chin is that there's a
cocaine lever shown here and then above
that lever every time the animal gets
cocaine it also gets a cue light above
the cocaine lever and the animals come
they learn to pair this cue light with
the cocaine or the feeling of cocaine
that they get with the cue light so that
at a later point in time once they've
learned to press that lever for cocaine
they will press the lever just to
receive the light so it would look
something like this this is just sort of
an average and a self administration
protocol and on the left side is shown
on the y-axis has shown the responses
these are the what we call active lever
the leather that gives cocaine it's
usually another lever in the box that
gives nothing at all called the inactive
lever shown at the bottom in green here
so the animal will fairly quickly
depending on the dose of cocaine will
fairly quickly learn to press the lever
for cocaine and maintain a certain level
and then you can take the cocaine away
from the animal
and so usually a quite a surprise the
first day on this day of extinction the
animal press the lever more you know
desperate attempt to try to get some
more cocaine but they will also fairly
rapidly extinguish this response and
they learn not to work for nothing so
they press the lever and get nothing
during extinction and then what you can
do is to give that cute light again just
a single what we call a priming cue
light it just Prime's the animal to
start pressing the lever again the
animal is not receiving cocaine but it
will continue to press the lever for a
period of time just for the cue light
and this is the reinstatement of that
behavior that was extinguished this is
our equivalent of relapse in animal
models so this is what we saw when we
asked the question do we need paranormal
masks for the acquisition or this
initial consolidation of cocaine memory
when they're learning to press a lever
to get cocaine so I'm the y-axis again
is showing these active lever presses
and you can see in the blue these the
blue line is showing what happens in
vehicle rats they acquire this habit
whether you're acquired the lever
pressing behavior takes about 10 days to
show kind of a maintenance level or a
steady level of self administration then
you can see that in our animals that
have no paranormal Nets this is a slower
response and it never quite catches up
to the vehicle controls so again we
blunt we don't completely block but we
do seem to blunt that acquisition or
consolidation of that cocaine associated
memory by removing nets in the
prefrontal cortex and then we also
looked at we've just begun looking at
reconsolidation using this self
administration model and for this where
it's a little bit takes a little
explanation but if you look at the left
hand side of this timeline at the top
the self administration training I said
here in fr1 and that means that every
time the animal pushes the lever for
cocaine it gets a single injection of
cocaine the fixed ratio one so
which once get a cocaine injection and
we do this for ten days and after that
period then we inject CH ABC your
vehicle and the prefrontal cortex to
remove Nets wait a few days and then
hear what we were doing on where it says
we activate and br5 and read what we
were attempting to do was to update the
memory in this case the animals have
pushed that lever hundreds of times
under that so-called fr1 schedule
they're used to getting a cocaine
injection every time they push the lever
in this case we essentially trick the
rats and say well you need to get out of
that sort of habit responding pushing
that lever and expecting a cocaine
injection and instead we're going to
fool you a little bit we're going to
make you press maybe once maybe twice
maybe nine times an average of five
times on a randomized schedule so
basically the animal has to learn kind
of a new protocol and so it doesn't
quite know what to expect
and here we think we're creating an
error signal this is some work that was
done a few years back by jonathan lee
showing that that to update a memory and
therefore make it labile again we may
need to kind of trick the animals and
make them update their memory so this is
our attempt to update the memory is to
give the animal a 30-minute session to
reactivate the memory but again under
this variable ratio of five scheduled
and then the next day we give them a
very short extinction session and then
we give them that cube priming where we
give them one light stimulus and then we
let them go to town and they can press
the lever as much as they want during
these last sessions what we found I'm
just showing you first what we found for
the last three days of training no bun
has been treated yet with the CH ABC so
we expect animals to be the same this is
just showing the Lillis the last three
days of training days eight nine and ten
animals are pressing the lever for
cocaine then we reactivate the memory
and you can see that they show the same
lever pressing behavior during
reactivation whether they have nets or
not they're still pressing the same
then we give that extinction session and
we also saw no differences here but when
we give them the cue light again the
vehicle animals show a nice increase as
expected to press just for the cue light
because that has become associated with
the feeling of cocaine
however in animals that have their nets
removed we see no increase in lever
pressing behavior we suspect this is
probably a disruption of the
reconsolidation but we are really at the
beginning of the study so we would like
to continue to pursue this so in summary
then of these data we believe that for
the consolidation process of this
cocaine associated memory we need intact
Perry neural nets and we also need them
for the reconsolidation process to occur
so that's what I've shown here one of
the issues though is that we got-we we
do this enzyme this kind of artificial
situation where the given enzyme take
many animals to destroy them nets so we
wanted to kind of flip the question on
completely around and ask the question
what happens in intact rats what is the
impact of cocaine exposure itself on
Perry neuronal Nets and in particular we
were interested in the intensity of
these Nets because we believe that the
intensity of the Nets matters so how do
these Perry in a room when that's change
after cocaine exposures there have been
some studies most of these have been
done just in the last couple of years
ongoing studies and while we were while
we're continuing ours as well and they
found that P&N intensity is altered
after cocaine after ethanol and after
nicotine and I won't go through the
details of this but I put the papers up
here for your interest so you can take a
look at these on but the bottom line is
these Nets have been shown to be much
more dynamic than originally thought and
they appear to be the changes appear to
be dependent on the drug itself in a
class of drug on the amount of drug on
the withdrawal time and with all times
from the drugs and also the brain area
that's
examined and here you see the cerebellum
the insular cortex orbital frontal
cortex and VTA have been examined and we
were particularly interested in what
happens in the pre limbic part of the
prefrontal cortex early after cocaine
exposure and so we also looked at this
part of human expression because as I
said most part of albumin cells and the
medial prefrontal cortex are surrounded
by nets and parvalbumin expression may
be very important for the firing of
these very fast spiking neurons so we
did the simplest experiment possible
first by just giving either a saline or
a cocaine injection and then waiting 2
hours of 24 hours later and looking at
what piece the intensity of the nets
were and the intensity of parvalbumin
neurons underlying those nets and then
secondly on that picture is shown here
the red staining for parvalbumin and the
green again the pairing around the net
surrounding those cells and secondly we
looked at five days of exposure this is
not a lot of exposure but there have
been a number of studies that look at
just IP cocaine injections and so we
thought well perhaps we could compare
some of our studies with previous work
that's been done so we gave five cocaine
or saline injections and looked to 24
hours later for peri normal net staining
and parvalbumin staining and in general
what we found you get to talk is that
one day of cocaine decrease the
intensity parvalbumin and paranormal
maps
raised five days of cocaine produced
just the opposite response that increase
the intensity so looking at the graph if
you look on far left this in the green
we see that compared with controls
there's a decrease it's not a huge
decrease but it's a significant decrease
in the intensity of the Nets two hours
after a single cocaine injection and
this has returned to normal 24 hours
later if you look after in the second
graph here after five days of cocaine
two hours later we don't see a decrease
anymore and in fact we see an increase
in the in the
intensity of those Nets perhaps the
thickness of those nets and that returns
24 hours later for cargo beam and we see
largely the same picture everything's
just perhaps a little bit delayed but it
pretty much manures what we see with
these peri neural nets so we see some
pretty dynamic changes that happen
within two hours but as you can see
they're opposite in opposite directions
depending on whether it's just a single
cocaine injection or five days now
interestingly we and others have found
that the intensity of the pairing realm
on that string on the y-axis is
correlated fairly tightly with the
parvalbumin intensity and as mentioned
this is found by others and by some of
our studies and we don't know what this
means but it could mean that these these
molecules or they at least some
molecules in net along with parvalbumin
are Co regulated in some way and this
has not yet been determined so what we
find in summary of these studies is that
in naive animals we see a certain
thickness or certain intensity of the
net in animals that receive one day of
cocaine we see a decrease and so I've
shown this as a decrease in the net here
and we believe that this decrease in
intensity could allow for the formation
of new synapse formation as I mentioned
early on those holes in the net appear
to or the structure of the net appears
to prevent new synapse formation so if
you make that net thinner we perhaps
allow new synaptic inputs to come in and
therefore potentially consolidation of
new memories in this case cocaine nomen
and then after five days of cocaine you
see the opposite response we see what we
think is a thicker net or at least a
more intense net and in this case this
may not allow for new synapse formation
and in some way allow for the
consolidation of strong memories and
that is perhaps we have kind of locked
in if you will these cocaine associated
noise one of the things that we're
interested in is looking at those this
new synapse formation in particular we
have some
early studies that just show synapse and
one labeling so just to look at general
synapse so enough tick in puts we don't
know if these are true synapses but
synapse one labeling increases in
animals after CH ABC treatment and this
was about two weeks after CH ABC
treatment we're also very interested in
pursuing whether what kinds of synapses
these are if they're glutamatergic shown
on the left here if it's labeling with
the gluten one or or GABAergic labeling
these studies have been done by dr. Lynn
Churchill also at Washington State
University and ongoing collaborative
work with dr. C licker at Oregon Health
and Sciences in university so then we
just have started to look at the
potential mechanism for changes in in
intensity and for this we've looked at
oxidative stress as a mechanism and the
reason that we did this was that there's
some evidence that peri neuronal nuts
protect their underlying cells from
oxidative stress and secondly that
cocaine itself induces oxidative stress
through its generation of reactive
oxygen species so we came back to the
simple question and asked what does one
day of cocaine exposure do to to the
nets and oxidative stress marker so one
day of cocaine we know increased
dopamine dopamine we do know can
increase reactive oxygen species and
increase oxidative stress so what we did
was to give an antioxidant an acetyl
cysteine or nak and we from many many
studies know that this increases
glutathione and with these decreased
oxidative stress so we gave this back or
vehicle a couple of hours before they
received a single saline or cocaine
injection and then again we waited this
two-hour window and looked in this case
at staining for carrying around one s
the part of human and then also a toxin
D G which is an oxidative stress marker
and so what we shown on the Left panel
or the photomicrographs of that labeling
and we were interested in
looking at a tox of DG no neurons that
were part of human neurons surrounded by
Nets as well as those that were not
surrounded by Nets so looking at the
right hand upper panel what you can see
is if you look at the white bars we just
normalized everything to say lean
vehicle animals that receive saline and
vehicle Connecticut see in the black bar
that cocaine does increase the oxidative
stress marker a little bit by about 20
percent and that's this is prevented by
pretreatment with the antioxidant neck
but we see in in part of a human
containing cells that do not contain
nuts is a different story this is also
an ongoing study but so far what we see
is this increase in Nets and it seems to
be that we've got cumulative effects or
potentially additive effects of both
cocaine and action on the far right bar
and we're not quite sure of what's going
on we have some ideas but clearly the
parvalbumin cells without nets look very
different from the parvalbumin cells
with Nets so overall it appears so far
that these perineural nets protect
against cocaine-induced oxidative stress
we also are just at the beginning of
some electrophysiological studies and
this is done with in collaboration with
dr. Travis Brown at the University of
Wyoming and what he's done is to give a
saline or cocaine injection again as
before wait two hours and then look at
prefrontal cortex cell firing and in
particular looking at these fast biking
and inter neurons that contain Nets as
well as fast spiking in turn-ons that
did not contain nets in in this deep
layer of the prefrontal cortex and
layers 5 & 6 where the pyramidal neurons
have their outputs to the nucleus
accumbens what he's found so far
is pretty clear and that is that these
fast biking neurons that do not contain
nuts show fewer spikes so on the left
hand graph is shown on the y-axis the
number of spikes as the current is
increased
you can see in the clear in the open
symbols saline treated animals there's
an increased increase with the current
and a decrease in that in that ramping
up so basically cocaine treatment just a
single day and two hours later decreases
the number of spikes however you see on
the right-hand side the same number of
spikes that in other words no
differences between saline and cocaine
treated animals so it appears that pn
ends prevent that cocaine-induced
decreases in the number of spikes so
again there's a lot of work to do we
have a lot of questions ahead we're
really interested in how these neurons
are firing differently and then again
and how these neurons might be different
when we remove nets these are all as a
reminder these are all intact animals so
in summary then we have the naive
animals as I showed the or we have
potentially extra inputs extra synaptic
inputs coming in after a single cocaine
injection the decrease in the Nets the
increase in oxidative stress but the
consequence of this we believe is that
we may enhance cocaine and ease
plasticity because of the added inputs
that are coming in that may be specific
for cocaine associated memories and then
again after multiple exposures to
cocaine we see potentially this
inability for new synapses to form this
is something that we're currently
measuring an increase in PNM's which may
be some sort of protective response from
oxidative stress up to multiple
injections of cocaine but the
consequence of this would be that these
neurons may be resistant to new
plasticity and this may be akin to what
has been described many times over in
the addiction literature and that is
that natural reinforcers do not seem to
induce the plasticity once once
individuals or animals have been exposed
to cocaine and so this
distance to new plasticity may in court
be occurring at the level of these
GABAergic best spiking neurons and
finally and I would like to thank all
the individuals in my lab who have
generated this work and collaborators at
Washington State University the
University of Wyoming and Oregon Health
and Science University know as I also
like to thank our local alcohol and drug
abuse research program as well as the
National Institute on Drug Abuse and I
would like to thank all of you who are
participating in this seminar thank you
thank you dr. zorg for that fabulous
presentation we want to get right to the
questions and input so here's a reminder
as to how audience members can
communicate with us questions can be
submitted via the Q&A button at the
lower left we will try to get to all of
you but if not we will be sure to follow
up after the broadcast so let's take our
first question dr. zorg how long does it
take PN's to return and do they wrap
around the same neurons we have some
excuse me we have some idea of how long
these tape but there are many questions
that remain what we've tested so far is
the Perry neuronal Nets we've tested out
to one month later with the dose of the
chondroitin SABC that we deliver which
is pretty moderate dose relative to many
of the studies that are out there and
some have shown that it could take up to
two months to reform these nuts fully we
do not see quite a full recuperation of
these nets one month later and we do
believe that the intensity of those Nets
matters because there have been for
example knockout and knockout mice that
have one of the critical proteins of
linked protein that I mentioned earlier
when they're knocked out those nets are
still there but they're very thin and
not just not very well for
and in those animals when those have
been knocked out in the visual cortex we
see or I should say on James faucets
loud they they've observed that those
animals are still maintained that
plasticity as juvenile like states
plasticity so we believe that those
fully formed Nets are really critical
for the for the sort of closure of that
plasticity period in terms of how how it
whether they're not they form around the
same neurons no one is sure you know we
would very very much like to answer that
question I believe they probably are
formed around the same neurons because
there are certain proteins that are that
are produced within the neurons that
have Nets around them and we believe
that the that the expression of those
genes is absolutely necessary for those
them here's another great question what
is the transition translational value of
removing p n ends for example could you
use CH ABC in humans so CH ABC has not
yet been used in humans to my knowledge
there is some work also by James fossa
looking at spinal cord injuries and the
ability to use pH ADC and you know you
know long term say in antivirus or in
hydrogels that would release the hav C
for the long term and allow the kind of
this reinstatement of plasticity new
synapse formation and then during
dendritic growth but but so far that has
not been used in humans one of the
things that we're very interested in is
targeting just the nets I did not
mention that the CH ABC actually
destroys for a period of time all of the
extracellular matrix and we know that
extracellular matrix molecules are
really critical for
all kinds of plasticity including
cocaine associated memories so one of
the things that we're interested in is
just targeting one of those proteins in
particular length protein so we're just
now getting underway with some
behavioural studies to look at whether
we can down regulate or in some way
knock down just that protein just that
link protein and knock down only nuts
but not disk or the surrounding
extracellular matrix so in that way get
us closer to a sort of a translational
picture in where we might understand
what components of them that are really
critical and then how we might better
target just those nets to be able to
bring that to from bench to bedside
Thank You dr. zorg we have time for one
more question
how does removing PN ends prevent memory
consolidation we don't have a good
answer for that yet and one of the
things that's really interesting is that
we can remove Nets after animals are
trained on cocaine and we see that we
can we get the full expression of memory
that is during that reactivation session
whether it was for conditioned place
preference or for self administration so
either of our models we found that when
we reactivate the memory the animals
look normal that is they don't have a
diminished response of the expression of
a conditioned place preference behavior
or pushing the lever for cocaine it's
only later when we test so the cocaine
itself that we give during reactivation
and/or in combination with the memory
reactivation is somehow initiating a
series of responses and this could be
the new synapse formation it goes
responses that lead to the
the maintenance of memory and so in a
case when there are no Nets we cannot
maintain that memory at a later time but
when it's tested at a later time so for
example a good example of this is just
thinking about when we reactivate the
memory perhaps reactivation of memory
allows for new glutamatergic synapse
formation onto those part of albumin
inter neurons that then inhibit any
subsequent behavior so they would
inhibit the output of the prefrontal
cortex you know and therefore inhibit
that a reinstatement behavior and that's
what we've seen what we need to do is go
in and measure what is happening with
that new synapse formation may happen
very rapidly it's in a few hours so
those are the kinds of questions that we
need to address
thank you dr. zorg your fabulous
presentation do you have any final
comments for our audience well thank you
I just think this is a wonderful format
to present and to allow a number of
individuals to participate I'm looking
forward to to attending the seminar
myself so thank you for the opportunity
if we weren't able to speak directly
with you today we'll be sure to follow
up with you thank you for taking part we
want to thank today's presenter as well
as joining us here at lab roots comm the
leading scientific social networking
site for more information don't forget
to visit us at WWE today is webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing on
our website through six months from live
date we will let you know when it's
posted and we hope you pass this
information on to your colleagues who
couldn't take part in today's broadcast
see you next time goodbye